the way the President appeals to the
worst instincts of people what was
shouted and chanted at the rally last
night without the president of parading
them was despicable despicable and
eerily familiar to what happens in
dictatorships we all know that the only
way the President Trump will stop this
is for Americans for Republicans rather
his own party to demand it the only way
President Trump will stop is when
Republicans on the other side have the
honor the decency the courage to tell
him to stop and all we hear is silence
and diversions from leader McConnell so
America if you don't like what the
president says if it gets you upset
makes your hair stand on end say this is
not the America I know and love whatever
our political views call your senator
and tell them to tell President Trump to
stop this argue the merits argue the
issues stop this appeal to the worst
instincts the worst instincts and our
Republican friends are silent history
will show this this is a moment there's
no John McCain anymore when this kind of
bitter racism emerged at his town-hall
meeting he rejected it publicly when
somebody used it against then candidate
Obama and went down his history as one
of his finest moments where are the fine
moments of my colleagues fifty-three of
them on the Republican side not one has
spoken out strongly enough not one